hey i've got a white male six foot three
he's got a crowbar
and i have and he's trying to break into
this building here's the address
i've just given them a description of
the suspect a description of the crime
and the existence of weapons every
single police department in the nation
that's what their dispatch is designed
to do and they just described
this at his own house practicing crowbar
combat i know right
yeah i feel like god
you look fantastic this is the best this
is the best i've ever looked if i look
in a mirror i've never seen this
coming back so whatever this camera is
doing for me
this is just know if you're watching
this i'm uglier than this looks right
now so no
i'm uglier than this looks i think you
kind of look celebrity-ish like you got
cool hair
a cool beard i think you look i think
you look like i think you look cooler
than you've ever looked
thank you that's how i feel i feel cool
and i think i need a tattoo or something
i'm just like now i'm trying to triple
down on the celebrity status that i i
see
no i i think you look wonderful um two
things
first today i want to talk about paid
communities a lot
but before we get into that the second
thing is what i want to tell you last
night
my wife sarah goes good night sean
um because
everyone's been saying that dude they
say it in such a
mean way was she trolling or was it an
accident he's trolling because
someone tweeted like well we think that
you are sean and sean do because
indian guys typically have high pitched
nerdy voice and
white guys like you have like low
pitched
alpha voice it turns out shawn's the one
with the alpha voice and i'm like
so she called me uh thank you oh that's
amazing
i hope you guys were doing some great
things while she called you sean that
was awesome
yeah well she burned me good but uh
let's get right in you want to get you
want to talk about paid communities i
did a lot of research because this
interests me right now okay let's do it
okay so paid communities interest me
because i came across this thing called
tiger21
and this sounds like lame that i'm
bringing this up now after selling the
company but i've been interested in this
for
for years um do you know what tiger 21
is
i've heard about it what i know about it
it's kind of like a mastermind peer
group thing but it's for a certain
wealth
level i don't know if there's a i don't
know if there's an actual cutoff but
it's supposed to be for wealthier
and i think it's mostly older people and
uh we have a couple friends who are in
it so i i texted one of them today about
it so i got a little bit of info but
tell me what i missed what do you know
about it okay so tiger21
uh google it i don't know the url maybe
maybe just that.com
um but basically it's a peer group where
you have to have at least 10 million
dollars of investable assets
in order to join it's very expensive
it's 30 000
a year i wouldn't call it a mastermind
because mastermind has a certain
connotation but
yeah it kind of is that um i logged on
to the site
i'm not a member but uh i used a
friend's login to check it out
and there's uh at least 850 members
according to the what i saw
and according to their site so what's
that map 24 million dollars a year in
revenue
um they have local chapters that meet up
uh i guess now digitally and they do
things like they share
one another's portfolio and you have to
defend your portfolio
and so it's basically rooted in rich
people
talking about rich people stuff mainly
being investing but i think it turns
into a little bit of therapy every once
in a while like a lot of groups do
but what did your buddy say all right so
i texted uh our mutual friend
keith um and he's
he's uh he's a real estate guy he's been
on the pod you can go listen to keith's
episode
and keith's a good dude and he goes i go
you're in tiger 21 right and he goes yes
um what's up and i basically asked him
what do you think about it
he's like it's an interesting group it's
because it's all about investing
preserving wealth
it's mainly for older people and um
he goes the typical meeting goes four
hours
you do like you said a portfolio defense
where you talk about what you're holding
and why
and other people get interested in it
and sometimes there's speakers
um sometimes it's sometimes an external
speaker
sometimes it's somebody from the group
who speaks and there's like a moderator
and they also do like events because if
you go to the website you can see like
they hosted a
tiger 21 event at magic johnson's house
and so they're definitely trying to
build this kind of like
who's who network this sort of like soho
club
soho house vibe uh to the whole thing
and it uh yeah so they do that they also
you get like deals so a friend of mine
sent me a deal where they
basically when you're wealthy you get
this thing called umbrella insurance
which you paid two grand a year and it's
just like
general insurance and it's basically the
story they tell you
is like if you get in a car crash and
someone googles you they're going to see
you're rich and they're going to want to
sue you for 5 million
and this protects against all types of
stuff and so
they give you a discount on umbrella
insurance um and so
by my calculation i actually would bet
they do 30 to 40 million in revenue
and they recently sold to private equity
and so it's a relatively big business
and i actually read about
uh read up on it and someone said like
there's 90
retention rate which is pretty amazing
i've also been following reddit's
fat fire which is a subreddit similar to
this
and it's like tripled over the last year
so this space has got me incredibly
interested
but this is just one example of a paid
community and so what i wanted to do was
go through a few other paid communities
that are interesting i want to explain
i'm going to try to explain why i think
they work and then where the opportunity
is for other paid communities
can i start can i start with one
opportunity which is why isn't this just
a business model for our podcast
like why aren't we starting tiger 21 for
people that are you know
that have let's call it a million
dollars of investable assets so a
million dollars of sort of like liquid
net worth
that you can go invest into something
and uh why aren't we starting this now
this seems like the perfect thing to do
for a podcast like this
i think that probably there should be
something like this i agree
if you go to the tiger21 website um
you'll see
like you know the type of models that
people use on their website is like
their ideal customer and it's like
65 year old white dudes who
own insurance companies that are quite
wealthy but not
young or not like our kind of
crew um so i agree i think there's
something there
okay fair enough so let's go into it all
right
so let's talk about where should we
start i've done a bunch of research um
how about we talk about by the way
sorry sorry interrupt you one more time
the thing i just said by the way i think
is important uh
i said why isn't that the business model
for this podcast i think
way too many podcasts try to just do ads
and we've talked in the past about like
super cast which lets you do like a paid
a paid kind of super premium version of
it for your hardcore fans who pay you
nine bucks a month or five bucks a month
or whatever and uh
you know i started a rolling fund
largely off of
the audience from this thing that said
hey i've listened to this guy a bunch i
trust him
he's he has a good track record and so
now that rolling fund is four million
dollars a year that i get to invest into
startups
that's more value than all of the ad
revenue that we had
before um and so i think that more
people should figure out
business models that are different from
the content that they're creating and so
i'm surprised more podcasts don't have
different business models i agree with
you but
we are working we're in one of the most
lucrative niches
there is i mean like if you're a
comedian if you're um
what's that called the two women
who talk about sex all the time
call her daddy yes like that's a little
bit different so how do you make money
off that that's a little bit different
and that's actually what we're gonna
talk about with pay communities so let's
actually
up let's and i'm going to bring that up
so let's talk about what makes them
interesting and what makes them not
interesting so to me what makes them
interesting
is that they can grow pretty quickly so
you had a podcast um you do this four
million dollar fund
now building the audience takes a while
but you turned your fun on and you
it was four million dollars in a matter
of months very quickly
so they seem relatively fast to grow
they're really fast if you have an
audience
but compared to like a software company
which would take 10 years i think you
definitely could build it
in a matter of two or three years second
they seem pretty fun to run if the
interest
of your community is the same interest
that you have if you if
you if they don't then it's definitely
not as fun but it's kind of interesting
if you're very interesting if that's
what you care about
third you don't really need a lot of
money to start one you kind of actually
need no money you really could just
start with a paid
facebook group and you could have a
really lean team to do it
and finally they definitely seem pretty
profitable because you can have a lean
team but let's talk about the cons
one and this is what i've learned with
our paid stuff
and from friends i think churn could be
pretty high did you notice that churn
was high in any paid communities you've
been part of
honestly the churn was not high in the
paid community that i ran
um i don't measure the year yeah yeah
for sure but i was
it was a monthly it was a monthly fee so
you could churn out monthly right for
trends i think you charge
annually so you don't know your churn
until you know sort of later unless
somebody actively cancels
so it's not like uh like enterprise
software
return where it's like a net like a 100
negative yeah so that that i don't think
that exists in most communities by the
way my
my paid community just for real numbers
mine was seven percent a month was
churning which is
like if you just if you're not adding
any new members you know that doesn't
take long for it to go to zero
but i think seven percent is one year
no i'm talking about monthly i was
monthly i was
churning seven percent and so uh so oh
you're saying one year for it to go to
zero
yes i think if you have a i think if you
have a four percent churn that's 18
months
and and so when with including my growth
i think my net
churn was like one percent so i think i
was adding six percent
and i was losing seven percent basically
every month and um
can you share anything about trends what
was the retention like yeah um
so we had some payment issues when we
first launched so basically
we had some issues um where if someone
signs up
on day one and on day 366 they get a
renewal
um the credit card statements there a
lot of the banks will be like whoa whoa
whoa what's this that's fraud
so we actually had a big fraud a problem
with banks blocking it but 80
of people uh were opted in to uh renew
in the year one or in renew in year two
in our first cohort
um ballpark ballpark about 80 which is
pretty good
but not but like it's hard to get new
customers on a consistent basis
yep um okay so uh the second thing is
a lot of times they don't scale that
well and the reason they don't scale
that well
is if your community is kind of like
trends
where you value close-knit connections
or tiger 21
more people makes it actually worse
now if your community is content based
which we're going to talk about in a
second
it can actually make it way better but
a lot of communities like a ypo like or
um
like if there's 150 people at your
meeting versus five people at your
meeting
one is worse than the other the scale
gets worse for two reasons one is
exclusivity so if the reason to be in
this group was that it's exclusive the
more people in
the less exclusive it is or the if the
value is that
oh i really like this conversation this
conversation was really
really nice but now you get a noisy room
of a thousand people
well now it's just too noisy i can't
keep up with this i don't know who these
people are
some of these people are saying stupid
things i'm out of here right so that's
the two reasons that the scale
scalability hurts
yes and it can work though because if
you're a reddit which is a community not
a paid community but it's a good
community
um you want more you need more you need
way way
more people if you are um quora
you need way more people if you're some
of the other examples that you need
you need way more more people is good
and that's great
um but it's not always good to add more
people
so what i want to talk about is a few
communities that i found that i think
are interesting and then i want to talk
about
opportunities in the space and then
finally we can talk about what i think
you need to build a successful community
um so the first one that i discovered
and i've actually brought up here a ton
it's called aventa have you seen aventa
no
okay so eventa i know the first example
is gonna it's
like doesn't even entirely apply because
i think aventa is actually a free
community
but you need to apply and eat or get
invited so it's somewhat similar but
eventa
is a community is a professional group
um i believe it has
uh 18 000 participating members and it's
for executives
particularly uh are you on the website
right now
no i'm on our our notes okay uh
basically it's for fortune
500 or fortune 100 people um it's people
like the i don't even like because i've
never worked at a company i don't even
understand all these roles but like a
cio
was that a chief information officer so
uh i said c-s-o i'm looking at their
website
um c-i-s-o i don't even i don't know
what c-i-s-o means it was that chief
information security officer
yeah cso yeah so these are like
things that i don't even oh i guess they
have cfo i know that is cheap
uh financial officer so it's basically
executive
you just turned into a glossary section
for sam to figure out
well you know what the role phro is yeah
that's basically your hr
chief hr officer basically okay i guess
that one was easy
a cdo i don't know that one
chief data management officer because
come on
a lot of people aren't gonna know what
this stuff is but it's a big thing
they have 18 000 members and check this
out
they sold in 2016
for close to 300 million dollars it was
375 million
they sold for and it was for 12 times
profit which means their profit was 23
million dollars a year
and almost all of that profit came from
sponsorships and so the way it works is
is that uh they would get groups of 10
or 20 people they would host a talk
uh like i think it was mostly an online
talk that says like
how walmart is gonna handle
how walmart is gonna promote work remote
work
and ten people like i'm just gonna guess
what's a fortune 500 so like the cmo of
northern
i'm looking at now the chief information
officer of northern trust i don't know
what that is but it sounds like a huge
company
uh the cio of um delta
of chevron of nestle is going to go
which is like it's only 10 people at
that talk but it's 10 people who each
control
20 000 people and sponsors will
pay stupid amounts of money hundreds of
thousands of dollars to reach these
people enough that it makes
25 million dollars a year in profit uh
very interesting an interesting
community again like tiger 21
if you go to the website it just kind of
looks like
pretty old school mostly older white
people
so who knows if it's if it's hip or at
least like in the know of everything
but where's that where's this land with
you interesting uh it's interesting but
i think you know if i'm most people i'm
like okay the hard part of this is going
and getting the cio of nestle or the
cmo of delta to join some group how do
you do that and i remember
what's the name of the the mastermind
group that's the more popular
company not tiger 21 but like the other
one we've both studied i can't remember
the name
ipo young presidential organization no
no the
the one that does like a hundred million
dollars a year uh
it's a competitive ypo yeah oh uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what's that i
don't remember what that's called
uh except for the c i think it slips my
name is what is
this as well anyways
so vistage uh does the same thing as
this and i remember getting
phone calls saying uh from some you know
pick up some random number and it was
hey sean you know this is wendy from
vistage
uh okay have we have we met um
yeah actually i've heard a lot about you
um you're the ceo
of monkey inferno right yeah that's
right uh again
like where do we meet no no see i'm i'm
actually
the chapter president for san francisco
for vistage and um i actually want to
invite you to join our ceo network
uh we have ceos from this company this
company this company
and uh we just really think you'd be a
great fit for for our ceo group we meet
up about once a month in san francisco
um it's a great time blah blah blah
okay ceo group you you sound like you
know me you're talking about my city
this sounds pretty legit
um okay so what are you asking me for
yeah so the membership is twenty
thousand dollars a year and uh
and i was like oh okay this is a sales
call uh
like good job you got 45 seconds into
the sales call
and so this is how them and i don't know
if it was them exactly but it was a
company just like them uh was recruiting
people was just they were just cold
calling c-level people with a script
that made you feel like they were
calling for you uh based on your city
and your company name and your role your
job title there
and so i think this is what you would
have to do is you'd have to be a pretty
badass cold caller
and you'd have to figure out how to get
this thing going with just enough brand
names where this sounds
legitimate i look i host an event called
hustlecon i've over the years i've
probably had 150
speakers um tens of thousands of
attendees
when i started it i didn't know any of
these people i cold emailed them and
there's a way to play it off that it's
cool to be part of
um there's a way to get customers i
think that's a little bit better than
cold calling and now i think cold
calling cold emailing like that
should exist and you should do that i
think there's a few different ways
like having a podcast uh there's a few
interesting ways to do it
um but nonetheless i think it's an
interesting community the second one
that i want to bring up
and i got hold of their deck uh a year
ago and i could have invested into it
and i skipped it i passed and i think
that might have been a mistake but it's
called soul savvy have you heard of soul
savvy
it's like a shoe thing yeah it's pretty
interesting it's
a sneaker head lover community something
like that yeah so it costs 33
a month and you basically when when i
was
got their deck it was basically just a
slack group that's all it was
and i don't know if that's what it is
anymore but there's a lot of kids
probably grown people as well who are uh
want to get insider tips on when a
certain drop of a shoe is
and they somehow game the system like
it's what it's called
cook groups so there's these like groups
where they team up and somehow i don't
know anything about the space but
they somehow get insider information on
when a drop is gonna happen and they
and they collaborate and scheme together
on how they can get access to these
certain shoes
now what soul savvy's doing is they
started with shoes it was just a slack
group which i think is
stupid by the way i think if you're
building one of these on a slack group
that's not the right move
but they get they get because they have
a group of i think they have 5
000 members now so it's 160 000 mrr um
because they have this contingency of 5
000 like really big
shoe fanatics they can probably give
them special access to x y and z they
can do interviews with special people
it's kind of interesting they raised two
million dollars uh recently
they say that they're adding 400 people
to what to their waitlist a day
i don't know if that's true but yeah
it's an interesting
it's an interesting space nonetheless
what do you think of that
uh i think you did good by passing on it
i think it's a cool
business for the person who owns it it's
definitely not a
as constructor right now that i don't
see how that becomes a
super large business worth investing in
worth why they need two million dollars
and how they're going to turn that into
you know a 200 million plus company i
don't really see that because
like we said communities themselves this
you know these chat groups don't scale
and um you know you're looking for
diehards who are going to pay
if you're paying 33 a month right like
you know that's more than
it's like you're providing more value
than amazon prime
you know what i mean like that's double
that's triple the price of amazon prime
and so you know you really have your
yeah the hardcores are going to go for
it
but also the more people you let in the
more people who all have access to the
same information the same tips the same
drops that they're trying to go buy
the harder it gets for you to actually
go buy anything that's valuable so
i don't really see how this becomes a
big big
venture scale business but i think it's
a great idea for somebody who's a big
shoe fanatic to create a community like
this i think that's an awesome lifestyle
business to to own
and uh like if that's your thing that's
great i love it
i agree with you um so let's talk about
three i can can i give you can i give
you two characteristics i think make it
work
one is high passion um and then the
second one
is the ability to make money on the
other side so this happens a lot with
stock trading groups
so um there are a bunch of stock tip
groups out there
where people are looking for additional
information and they want to be in a
group where the crowd is moving a
certain direction
um you have this for sneaker heads you
have this for
nfts right now collectibles um so so
the key characteristic is it's not just
like i'm a big fan of the
you know the golden state warrior so i'm
going to join this paid community for
them
typically that doesn't work as well as
if i join this group
i'm going to get tools that are going to
help me make more money so it's a very
simple
money and money out calculation for
people and i think that's why it works
for sneakerheads
and it works for trading cards and it
works for crypto but it doesn't work as
well for like
you know people who just love gossip
girl yes so there's a few
ways i think that if you're going to
build this uh you've got to think about
the first is
the amount of money that your company is
going to make is exactly what you said
which is
it's directly in proportion to the
amount of revenue
that the uh attenders member can make
back
so for example if you are enthusiasts of
rc cars
um well the equation here is
how much revenue the attendee or member
is going to make times how many there
are so members of people who like rc
cars
i have no idea i just made that up but
there's probably not that many of them
and because it's like a hobby that you
don't really make any money from you
probably cannot charge a lot for it
so that like probably won't be massive
that's not
i mean maybe you should do it but that
doesn't mean it's going to be
actually that big so that's the math
that you have to do which is
how much revenue is the member going to
make and how many of those potential
members are there
right or or the one like you said with
tiger21 so tiger21 is actually like that
right
when you when you go and you hear
somebody's portfolio you're going to get
investment ideas
and even a single investment idea a
single like improvement to your
portfolio
if you have over 10 million dollars in
investable assets
one good idea is going to more than pay
for the 30 000
of your membership excluding the friends
you'll make and the deals you'll do
together and that real estate thing
you'll buy together and all that good
stuff
so excluding all that now on the other
hand if you're looking at something like
um the aventa or whatever where it's
like
what is the cmo of nestle gonna do when
she meets the cmo
of delta like they're not gonna directly
get revenue out of it i don't think
that's why
i think it's like how hard were how hard
is it to accumulate this group of people
in a room
so if it's really hard to reach these
people these are all high value people
then it's
the membership is worth the value of the
people in the group
so if it's just a bunch of sneaker head
buyers each individual member
is bringing zero like clout to the table
but if it's cmos of different companies
and it's about
how much clout do they need to bring to
the table that's the value not so much
how much revenue they're going to make
yes and so let's talk about three groups
that i have
that i think this could work for so if
you're going to start a paid community
i'm going to start with the bottom one
or i actually think it's the best one
but it's fun i'm on our list
nurses we've talked about nurses a ton
it's an interesting
demographic i think nurses are kind of
cool for this space for two reasons
or three reasons the first work could
pay for it maybe
i think work would maybe pay for it
second
nurses are typically i've spent time
around nurses so they're typically women
and they typically
are people who feel like downtrodden
like they feel like they're forgotten
because they're not worked overworked
underpaid or
underappreciated yeah and that so
groups that are the um
whatever you just said i guess i don't
know how to explain it but groups that
are like the
us versus them like we don't have
someone speaking for us typically that's
like
there's a lot of like i've looked when i
was researching communities there's so
many successful
um women like women discussing x y and z
communities this is just like that so i
think that they have that uh us versus
them mentality
and the third reason is there's a
ton of nurses yeah
have you seen this instagram account
nurse life rn
no how many is it it's 1.2 million
members
on instagram it's run by this guy i
think his name is eb
or ebby i'm not sure exactly how you say
his name and it's this guy
this is black nurse and um private
they just went private uh they used to
be public and i think you have to like
you have to request so that they can
make sure that you're a nurse before
they let you in
um which again is part one thing that
communities do well
the you know what's that quote it's like
i don't want to be a part of any group
that would accept me
um you know the better your gate at the
front uh the more people will value
being in the group
and so this is a group and they they
just post mostly like nurse memes
so it's like you know if you it's like
being underappreciated or whatever
they'll make a joke out of it or like
you know coming home and realizing you
still have whatever you know on your
shoe
and uh it's just you know relatable
memes from the eyes of a nurse
so that's how they like keep their
members engaged it's just meme content
that's a good like
inside joke for the community but he
partnered with the makers of
bala shoes which is the nurse shoe brand
that's coming out that's trying to be
nike for nurses basically
it's nike for for medical footwear and
so he got equity in that company
and gets paid every month because he is
the promotional vehicle
for the forbala shoes who wants to like
penetrate this community right so
um not a paid community as such but it
is a private community
and on top of that they do this now what
would incredible health
you know the startup that's raised i
don't know how much money 25 million
dollars from
entries and horowitz and all that what
would they pay to access 1.2 million
nurses that are like engaged and trust
this brand
and trust this leader of the community
they would pay a lot
right uh nurse job boards like so so if
this guy's ambitious he could create a
job board he could create the next
incredible health
uh he could take equity in abolish shoes
and be a part owner of the shoe brand
like
i think that's where this goes for for
nurses i think that's a great example of
one
i think this could crush i think that
guy is gonna that guy's sitting in a
gold mine that like
if you if you fast forward 10 years and
tell me that he turned this 1.2 million
person instagram page into a 100 million
dollar company i won't be surprised
right if you go and start truck life rrn
right now
uh i i think i think that's what's gonna
happen after this pod
truck um the second one this is shocking
to me okay
google sheets there's this guy who
tweeted at me and he started this thing
called
sheets con and he had 6 700 people sign
up
is that i mean i guess that's shocking
because
like i know that probably a hundred
million people plus use google sheets
but and i guess it doesn't and i guess
it also doesn't track me because i am a
google sheets nerd and like i've
dorked out about what i want and some of
the most
uh profitable online courses in the
world
are become an excel master how to use
excel
become better at excel those are like if
you'll go look at the charts of
uh most profitable online courses
highest revenue online courses excel is
always in the sort of top five
yeah encore the founder of um teachable
teachable
one time told me that uh there was some
guy making a million bucks a year and he
was like the biggest earner
on teachable on excel exactly
so google sheets i 100 think you could
do a paid community now it would have to
be cheap though because it's the same
it's the math of like how much money do
you make for google sheets i think that
there's absolutely something there
um and then the last thing is this
someone tweeted at me
a community of vetted senior engineers
who talk about advance advanced
engineering concepts like how to scale a
tech stack from 100k to 10 million users
totally buy into that something like
that that is incredibly niche and
incredibly high-end
where if there's a there's this other
component that we didn't talk about with
the community is you have to make it
so that information that you gather in
that group
you cannot find online like um for
tiger21
not that many people are going to talk
about how
like because it's embarrassing how do i
um
gift my child 15 million dollars without
the government getting
hands on it like that's not something
you're going to tweet because that's
embarrassing same thing with
100 000 to 10 million users there's just
simply not that many people who have
done it
you're not going to find a lot of
reputable information on that so that's
another trait of these paid communities
and why i think this one
in particular is interesting i think any
job
in any any job can do this so nurses is
a good one because you have
some are going to be better than others
because you have uh
you know the more people the more
potential and the more
um kind of like insider knowledge is
needed the more
um downtrodden that group feels
dumbfounded is kind of a negative word
but
kind of what you're saying like sort of
like they feel that they need to take
action
um in order to like level up in some way
uh the better and so like you know this
could work for nurses but it could also
work for designers i could see somebody
just making a community
of you know professional designers at
all these different companies it's like
yep we have designers from figma
and from hubspot and from octa and from
github
and you should if you're a designer at
one of these companies you're making
150 000 a year 200 000 a year um why
would you not want to be a part of the
like the best network of other designers
like you where you can share
tools tactics salary information if
you're looking for new jobs
opportunities if you're looking for new
jobs like every job i think
needs this and the more new infringe
your job
the more they the more the community is
needed so like i know that our friend
david spinks did this with community
because community was like this there's
not really like there's no chief
community officer at these big companies
but all greek companies say it's all
about community facebook's like it's all
about community
twitch is like it's all about community
and uh what does that mean and who in
your company show me your
who's in charge of community at your
company right and there's typically not
a c level who's in charge of community
so david spinks said well look there's
all these like
kind of mid-level people who are
community
they run community for these big ass
companies and
there's no playbook on how to do their
job they're underpaid they're
under-appreciated
and they're overworked trying to run all
these events i'm gonna make the best
community for community professionals
and so he made the community for
community people
it grew pretty large he ended up selling
the thing i don't know how big of a
business it was in terms of a business
outcome he might have been a little
early
but i think that's a great example of
somebody doing this just taking a job
and making it happen
so there's my idea i just wanted to talk
about communities
i think they're actually kind of cool
businesses i think a lot of people think
that they want to start one
but i also think that there's a lot of
mistakes made of like charging too
little
and i wanted to show a few examples of
companies that make like a quarter of a
billion dollars of value off communities
because i think they're kind of cool so
that's all i gotta say about communities
i'll leave it with this which is a lot
of people i think the majority
of people who listen to us they would
love a
non nine to five way to make ten
thousand dollars a month
and if i was gonna write or uh i read
that in your uh
your survey results yeah um
yeah which we could talk about that but
but in general that's
that's the number one thing i think
people listen to this would would just
grab right away they don't all want to
be founders of billion dollar companies
or 200 million dollar companies or
whatever
um but if i said hey this is something
outside your nine to five
it's a side hustle it doesn't take up
all your time and it's gonna bring in
ten thousand dollars a month
i would say that this to me right now is
the number one way to do it
i think there are some other ways right
you could try e-commerce or drop
shipping or something like that
you could try to do a newsletter or paid
newsletter i would do a community if i
was gonna
that would be my fastest path to that
right now and i'll tell you
you know the reasons why are all the
things you said which is like
it's not that much work to run the
members provide the value to each other
it's not all about you creating content
all the time
it's not that hard to spin up you just
have to be smart about which group
you're choosing and what
where you kind of have an edge what's
your group
and then the last thing the downsides of
it are that it can't scale super large
but that's not your goal anyways you're
just trying to get to ten thousand
dollars a month of free free cash flow
from your side hustle and so that is
super achievable you know
uh 20 a month for for 500 members and
you're there you know
so i think that is where i think this
business fits in and i
and i and i said before i actually do
think they can scale but not all of them
can
some of them some some of them can but i
i'm someone i've built a paid community
that makes
many many millions of dollars a year in
recurring revenue and
it is i would say that it's really hard
actually to start
because i had to create a lot of the
content early on and i had to create the
um the culture of the community but now
i barely post
and it has its own culture so yeah once
it's
once it's taken off yes you you create
that flywheel and it works or not
by the way i just did this i just did
this in e-commerce and it probably i've
probably put in a
grand total of maybe
eight hours into this thing and i'll
tell you what it is so i wanted to
create a community for people who have
e-commerce stores so i created a gate at
the front that said
your ecommerce store must be doing a
hundred thousand dollars a month
what's up it doesn't even have a website
there's no website
um it's called club ltv ltv is like an
inside
term in the ecom world lifetime value
it's like whatever e-com store owner
wants is their their ltv to go up
so i called it club ltv it's for people
trying to increase their ltv
and so i said you have to have a hundred
thousand dollars a month of revenue
i told so i tweeted it out so i
definitely had a head start because i
have an audience so
that brought in about the first 35
members you said yep and they would just
send me a screenshot of their dashboard
yep here's me this much
okay so so what i did was i made it free
to join for the
uh the store owners but you had to have
this much value like this much
you had to be this kind of far ahead in
the game um but what i did then was i
went to
sponsors and i basically said hey i have
a group of 75
store owners ranging from 1 million to
50 million
dollars a year in revenue and all of
them
trust me like me and i meet up with them
once a month and um would you like to
sponsor this so i have one sponsor on
board
they paid me 5 000 a month um all i do
is at the event i say
boom i do my intro my high energy intro
and then i say hey let me pass it to
the guy that makes this possible that
makes this group possible and he says
his thing for two minutes
he's had uh i can't say the names but
um i don't know if i should i guess i
just gave him a free plug so mercury
bank is the sponsor of it because that's
who i would use for e-commerce projects
and they're
they have a big push in e-commerce and
so they've had
at least from our group five different
um
five out of the 75 e-commerce stores
switched to mercury just from the
sponsorship so they've gotten their
money's worth out of it including
one companies that's a two billion
dollar company has switched over to them
and so
uh you know they definitely got their
value out of the sponsorship but
and is this still going yeah this goes
every month and so all that we do we
have we have
about one hour a month of of prep
and then 90 minutes a month of the
actual event and the the one hour of
prep is that
ben goes and gets a cameo made from a
different rapper every month
and the rapper's just shouting out club
ltv he's like so we had like you know um
we had uh sean paul do the cameo one
month and he's like
hey it's your boy sean paul just one of
them like big
big ups to club ltv you guys are all
doing so great with your ecommerce store
and he's like you know just
it doesn't even make any sense but it's
just like a video that plays and people
like it because it's like
i don't know it's kind of goofy so we do
one we get one cameo ordered
and he sends the calendar invite so just
make sure everybody gets it sends one
reminder email
and then the last thing is that after
the event he just says hey
if you learned something really useful
that you're going to implement in your
business um email me the one line of the
most useful thing that happened for you
in the hour
because the structure of it is we break
everybody up into groups of six
so you're in a group with six other
store owners who do between 1 and 50
million a year in revenue
and then the format is you say one thing
you did in the last month that's really
working it's driving revenue up
and one thing that you're struggling
with that you might want help from from
the group
and so afterwards they all email him the
most useful things he just comp
he just takes he just takes that sheet
and he just sends it to everybody so hey
here was the top insights from the group
so that whole thing takes in one hour
what's that why wouldn't you charge for
that because i can actually make much
more off the sponsorships
for example i've been approached by you
know the companies that want you to
build their e-com store on their
platform
there's the people who want you to use
them for email marketing there's the
people who want
for influencer marketing who are you
using for facebook advertising who are
using what's the agency that manages
your your
um your data tracking like your pixel
stuff so
all these companies each are willing to
pay multiple thousands of dollars
i just have to onboard them now um
because now i have the group and the
group is where the value is that's the
honeypot
it's the same thing you were talking
about where eventa they have a free
group and they might they have they are
making 25 million dollars a year on the
sponsors who want to talk more than that
oh sorry that's the profit
they're making 200 million but um that's
the same model that i'm using here don't
charge the members just make sure all
the members
have successful businesses and once they
think this is going to get or do you
care
i mean i put zero effort into it since
then but like we have 75 people who show
up every month to the thing
and um which is like 80 85
of the members show up every single
month to the event so it's they're
getting value out of it
and so i bet if i told ben hey go on
twitter and just reach out to these 250
cold email these 250 or these 500
e-commerce stores
because it's very easy to get lists of
e-commerce stores that are successful
um i bet we could triple the size of the
group if we if we put some effort into
it but
don't really care about it it's more for
fun but it's cool because it's just free
money every month
and it's a good group to be in i want to
learn from these people i want to learn
what they're doing what's working what's
not
and make these connections that's bad
apps well
you uh you know i it's funny i've
i've built the community as well but
it's like every time i learn
something like you the way you're doing
it is a lot different than the way that
we've done it and it's really neat to
hear a different
point of view and perspective uh on how
to get it done right
i optimize mine for how do i spend the
least time but get
just enough value whereas i think for
you is like a part of your business
you're like i'm gonna
this is gonna be a multi-million dollar
thing and we're gonna make it
awesome
which is awesome by the way if i had to
start over i would have done it
differently
um i would have charged way more money
right
um because i've learned the mistakes
that you have to
add a ton of people to build a big
business and a ton of people for certain
groups isn't necessarily good
right um fair play all right
one more quick one before we go uh only
if it's you because that's all i
prepared
okay um okay i kind of have like a
like a advice thing this is my psa this
is my public service announcement
um do you know what the word inertia
means
yeah it's like uh uh when something
starts moving it's hard to quit moving
yeah so i've noticed this and you tell
me
if you've if this has happened in your
life but i've noticed for myself and
many people that kind of asked me for
advice
inertia explains like 90 of why people
are doing what they're doing
right they're doing what they're doing
because they're already doing it
and sometimes that's good because like
hey the train's in motion so i kept
going
even when things weren't you know going
gangbusters but i just kept going
because it was it was already in
progress
and i'm glad i did because i had this
good outcome but more often than not
whether it's
your business your relationship with
somebody
um maybe it's something you've invested
in and why are you invested in it well
i already own it i don't want to sell it
okay but if i gave you that money today
would you buy it
no so it's like you know there's all
these weird things if
if i didn't if you weren't already doing
this business if i gave you a clean
slate
tomorrow would you go start this
business again no
then why the hell are you doing it right
and so in my life i've had this
kind of like weird moment many times
where i realized
inertia is a and inertia is
the reason i'm doing all these things
i'm doing not because i actually want to
be doing them or
think that it's the right thing to do
right now and so i just wanted to say
this for
to say see if this has ever applied to
you um
but b for anybody out there who's
listening to this and like something is
not going the way they want in their
life
coach like just check yourself like is
this am i doing these things because
i really think they're the right thing
to do and i want to do them or am i
doing them because this is just the way
that things were already going
and i i don't have the courage to change
it i remember with my company when we
sold our company
it's because i had a conversation with
my buddy silly and i you know
while we were talking we were trying to
figure out okay how do we make this
bigger how do we make this grow
and we were both looked at and we were
like i don't think there's like we don't
have great ideas like left
we've tried so many things we've white
boarded all these different ideas
it's like do we even believe that this
is a big opportunity like
knowing everything we know now would i
be still doing this opportunity if i
wasn't already doing
it and the answer was hell no and it was
like
so this was my test it's if this project
ended tomorrow for
whatever reason the company had to fold
would i wake up tomorrow and start
working on the same project and the
second question was
if the company had to dissolve the
investor you know the company went
bankrupt
and i needed to go start again would i
call these same people
like hey you want to work together on
the next thing because if i if no then i
have the wrong people today
if yes then i have the right people
today if i would call them again and so
for me it was always the people were
right
but the project was wrong and that's
when i decided look maybe i should sell
this instead of
keep going on this for another five
years and um
you know just sort of keep going with
the inertia so has this been a thing for
you in your life
yeah and i'll tell you how i combat it
and i think i'm actually really good at
combating this i think i'm i'm not great
at a lot of stuff but i'm good at
combating this and
warren buffett says it's like uh bailing
out water of a leaky ship
he's like it's sometimes it's better
just to get a new boat and the way that
i
get out of this is i do two things the
first is i burn bridges
so a lot of people say don't burn
bridges i say no i actually do burn
bridges
so quit your job or move to another city
or do something drastic
because for me i've said i cannot focus
on more than one thing at a time i can
only focus on
i can only focus on one thing at a time
and so in order to like get
to create to break inertia and create
new type of momentum
i like to create some something that i
have my back's against the wall
and i think more people should do that i
think that's the way to go um
they say that like once you have a kid
you your that changes
so that's one that's an example once you
get fired a lot of things change
so i like to create those moments where
i have
where yes i love those forcing factors
and the second thing that i tell that i
do and i actually tell people
is i say just do something really small
so for example if you're starting a
business
don't think about a million dollars what
can you do tomorrow that's just one
dollar
and creating little tiny things actually
helps a lot
um because breaking the pattern is quite
challenging
and i love burning bridges i think
that's the way to go
well you gave advice on two things there
you said basically you
you cut things off and you burn bridges
that's how you stop
current momentum and then how and when
you start you start with
ultra small baby steps or uh and i've
heard this now for many people so when i
went to this tony robbins event
he used to say he's like how many of you
like if you think in your life
has there ever been a decision that has
like altered the direction of your life
like obviously yes for all of us our
life is full of choices and if we have
made different choices we'd be in a
different spot right now
and so clearly like choice and decisions
are like
one of the superpowers that we have and
he goes
but how come there's times where you
know maybe it's like weight loss you
keep saying you want to lose weight you
keep deciding to lose the weight you
make that new year's resolution and then
you don't do it
right or this and that you know you you
say you want to quit your job you want
to start your business
then there you are nine months later
still in your job still with no business
and so he says like the word decision
we've kind of
we just used it too freely he goes the
word decision the root
word of it like decision is like kind of
incision
which is a cut and he's like the word
decision means to cut off the other
possibility
when you decide x you remove the
possibility for y
you cut it off completely and he always
says like
i forgot that um famous like story or
whatever but it's like
you know these people going the general
is going they're trying to surge
take over this island so they arrive on
boat and they're trying to
try to make it to land and trying to
take over the land and he says
you know if you want to if you want to
win if you want to win the war
get you got to burn the boats they say
like if the soldiers know there's no
boats there's no place to retreat
there's no boat to get back on and go
back home where you came from
they'll win this island and um so he's
you know the the story i guess i don't
know if there's real or not but the
story is the general burns all the boats
and then the
soldiers go and they win and same idea
so that's kind of what you're talking
about which is
you're better than most in that when you
make the decision
you literally cut off the other opera
option by physically moving
by sending that email by like or cheaper
or i make the old option really
embarrassing or hard to continue doing
so a good example is this is as we speak
i have i'm actually going to talk not
loud doesn't hear me
i have a chef in my kitchen cooking for
me
and it's very expensive it's a very
expensive fee
and i'm doing it because i'm trying to i
got actually really fit the summer time
and then i got a little chubby and now
i'm gonna get fit again and it cost me a
lot of money to have this guy here doing
this
and the reason i'm doing it is because
i'm gonna lose weight
quickly and eat only the food because
right i want to stop doing this
and so that works really well another
example is if you want to lose weight
you sign up for a competition like an
ironman
or something you can't get out of
something you cannot get out of and
those types of forcing functions
are the i have found for me personally
who's pretty lazy and stubborn
it's the only thing that works right i'm
the same way i want to use psychology
against myself
i want to use my own psychology against
myself so if i say something publicly
like we've said on this pod
we're going to grow this bot we're going
to make this a top 10 podcast this
podcast can be doing 100 000 lists per
episode we've said that
now egg on our face in front of all
these people that we think are cool and
we want to seem cool against
if we don't make it happen if we don't
if they don't see us taking the steps
and taking this seriously to make it
happen
so when they see us putting thousands of
dollars into our studio
adding video adding youtube uh doing
more research so we're coming onto these
podcasts more prepared
they see that we are taking massive
action towards it and we can't be
embarrassed on it tim ferriss used to do
this thing where he would say i don't
know if
i don't know how real this was or this
was just a thing he used to sell his
books but he used to say
if i wanted to lose weight i would give
my friend a 5 000
check and say donate this to the kkk if
i'm not this weight by
this date it's already in the envelope
you just have to put it in the mailbox
and that he doesn't want to lose the
money he doesn't want it to go to the
kkk he thought of the worst possible
outcome for himself that would give
give use his own psychology in his favor
to serve him in this case
yeah there's a business around that it's
called stick s-t-i-c-k-k
or it's spelled like with two k's or
something it's like a cute spelling
and you have a referee of a challenge
that you want to do you fund the account
with a certain amount of money
you pick something you hate and the
referee deans if you hit it or not and
then that money goes to your anti
charity right yeah i i think that's a
cool idea i think there's even more
people can do to like use
use our own psychology to get us to do
the thing we really want to do in our
life and of course you know like
these things are kind of external
motivators they're not great you know
like
what you would rather do is you know
build great habits and you would rather
be
internally motivated and make a decision
for yourself that this is this is like a
must for you you're going to do it
it's not a should um but but you know
some of these
these tools can help you get leverage
and i'll actually leave it with that
what
what changed what are you talking about
can you say or no
uh for what do you mean why did i bring
this up
yeah i was talking to a friend and
i just realized like i can help this
friend the friend just needs to make a
change
and then the rig realization was that
the friend didn't even want to be doing
what they were doing anyways they were
just doing it because of inertia and i
looked at my own life
and i saw all these different examples
of where inertia had
inertia was inertia had the drivers you
know had the wheel
and um inertia should not even be in the
passenger seat a nurse should be in the
trunk
and it's just something you carry with
you at the mo at the most and so
i just felt like i need to say this in
case there's somebody out there
listening for whom this happens because
when my friend was in that situation i
explained it and they were like dude
thank you like i needed to hear that
because it made it more clear
and now i'm kind of embarrassed that
i'll just keep doing this just because
of inertia like
no that's not a good enough reason for
me i'm gonna actually
choose the things i do and then for
better whatever they turn out at least i
chose that path
rather than like autopilot sleeping i
think there's a lot of people listening
that might say like
and i think you agree with me and like
taking drastic changes i think there's a
lot of people
listening who are like well that's
pretty reckless um and my answer to that
is
yeah if you want like a drastic outcome
you have to take a jurassic period
yeah or or like be honest what is the
real risk the real risk in almost all of
life is mediocrity
you know like my my trainer tells me
this all the time he goes most
people are so afraid of so many things
it's like there's a lion sitting in the
room
he's like and i'll be the first to tell
you look if there's a lion in the room
don't meditate
don't uh don't take deep breaths run if
there's a lion
run sure he goes but most of the time
there's no lion in the room
and basically what he's saying is like
the things that we
the things that we want to do we should
have the courage to do the reason we
don't do them is fear
and um and one other you know like we
should not be
fearful all the time because most of the
time there's no line in the room most of
the time the risk is much
lower than you think for the things
you're hesitating on
and the the real risk over the long term
is mediocrity is having a mediocre life
a life that's not on your terms that
isn't the way you want
and so um you know i think that's true
and i think you can apply this to
anybody like
abraham if you if if i if i say this to
you now
or as you've been listening to the
separate you is there a part of your
life that you
you think is like that's inertia that's
inertia driving not not
me choosing it could be doing this
podcast i don't know how long you've
been
i hope you won't say that it could be
though like because
bray has big dreams so brady wants to
start a company he wants to do all this
stuff
and he you know this pro this podcast
was a passion for him
and it turned into a job for him and i
don't know like is this what he wants to
be doing with his time
or does he have a bigger dream and he's
just doing this because he was doing
this i don't know
what do you think of bray what do we how
what this is a weird episode
this was the weirdest episode it kind of
became about me
but like that the community part felt
less like a podcast
and like we could charge for that there
was so much value in there for the right
person
i think for a lot of people listening i
think that's it was
not as entertaining as the stuff that we
normally put out i think
but it was more valuable if that makes
sense
yeah uh i don't know which one is best
so i guess we'll find out
speed at us so we know and just tweeted
us like i i don't know if
bray i don't know if a brave speaks for
the average listener we think he does so
that's why we ask him but if you're like
if you're like yeah i generally agree
with the braves grades then tell us
and if you don't agree usually and
you're like don't listen to that guy
also tell us go just go on twitter
or email us or something and i don't
blame you because i disagree with myself
so
oh also i put this out there uh
everybody put the link to the
hotline in the description of this i
want to start doing q and a's
where we take um ideally like
somebody asking a question like you
talking somebody asked this question we
play it
we respond to it or we take call-ins or
something like that but i mean say i
want to do some bonus episodes
i opted him into this i don't even ask
him if he wants to but we want to do
some bonus episodes
i committed to a third episode um
so and if it's a q a that's like the e
that's that's required zero work for me
so yeah i think it'll be fun so we're
gonna put a thing in it's basically a
hotline where you can just
ask your question to the mfm hotline and
we will get those we'll sort through
them we'll put the good ones
into the episode and we'll answer them
so uh do that
all right i'm out hey everyone we did an
interview with dave
sellinger aka selly he's the founder of
deep sentinel
really interesting home security company
dave is also
really interesting himself he's a
multiple time founder
really cool guy not only do the guys
discuss deep sentinel but they also talk
about some of the opportunities dave
sees in the moment
so we'll leave this interview here at
the end as a little bonus as a little
nugget
hope you guys enjoy and as always leave
us some feedback
so we're going to do a relatively quick
statement segment uh
dave do you go by david or dave uh go by
dave you go by sally most of my
my friends and co-workers call me sally
sally all right that's a good one
um selly s-e kelly uh
i dig it um okay so i invited you to
come on because i have this thing called
senegal deep senator i say it right deep
sentinel yep fentanyl um my friend noah
you mispronounced his name you
mispronounced his company
is your friend's name really nella yeah
i i
people make fun of me because i
mispronounce a lot of stuff but um
i have been using this it's quite
interesting and i want to give a summary
of what this is my friend gave it to me
basically
i had ring these ring cameras and ring
is
pretty good i mean it's fine it's
cameras but my friend noah was like
oh that's cool you can watch people
steal your um
and i was like what do you mean he's
like well i mean what's the point like
you got to monitor all them
and i was like yeah that's actually a
great point he goes here try this thing
called deep sentidol so i tried it
and basically what it is is it's a it's
a bunch of security cameras around my
house
and there's security guards watching it
all the time and if
something is triggered and uh they see
someone at my door that looks suspicious
or even just someone at my door they say
hey who are you
uh do you know the person who lives here
what are you what are you doing here
um whatever yadda yadda and i tested it
online
on my twitter handle and i like did the
secret sign you could like put your
hands above your head and do a sign
and someone checks and goes hey is
everything okay and it's just like
pretty badass and so
i invited you on because i wanted to
learn a little bit about this did i
describe the company
accurately you nailed it right like our
our motto really is
um and one of our one of our marketing
gimmicks is that we make a
a t-shirt that says oh you have ring
congratulations
uh you know now you can watch people
steal your and
that's and that's literally kind of
where no i got that is it
i personally have uh i have a ton of
cameras i've been a camera fanatic for a
long time
and my neighbor had a home invasion and
so you know the the neighborhood it's a
pretty scenario
we all freak out and we're like you know
what what can we do we have the police
come
and i introduce myself i'm kind of the
head of the the neighborhood watch and
blah blah
so i i asked the cop i say you know look
my neighbor she has all these cameras
she has an alarm system you know why did
she still get
a home invasion and the cop who i'm now
friends with by the way
says like the rudest possible thing
which is which is straight on point he
says
well you're the tech guy what did you
think the freaking cameras were going to
do and it was like this moment of just
utter eye opening wtf was i thinking
you're right like
they're just cameras and they don't
actually stop anything and so
i i spent the next five years building a
product that turns cameras into
something that can stop
crimes how many subscribers do you guys
have
we have uh about 2500 customers across
the country
about half of them are businesses and
half of them are are residential
and how many security guards do you have
and where are these security guards
so we're we're bordering on like kind of
the the secret sauce here but i'll tell
you
we have a ratio of about one guard for
every about 100 properties right now and
that's how we make it so that it's
affordable because
uh it's a hundred dollars a month kind
of our starting price point
and if you think about like having a
security guard at your house if you
happen to you know have a bunch of
friends who are billionaires for example
they're spending thirty to a hundred
thousand dollars a month
for a security guard and our our entire
point was like that's just
not attainable to most people but
security is really really important
how do we make it affordable and so we
use ai and like a bunch of technology in
the middle
to make it so that we can have one guard
protecting lots of properties at once
okay so you don't have to answer exactly
but if i had to guess and
i mean you just said it around 25-ish
security guards
a couple dozen a few dozen some some
number in that ballpark
yep um and how can this
how well the question that i had when i
was thinking about this business is two
things the first is
this whole idea of like someone real
life
actually doing manual work is like on
the other side of a
of a tech a tech product is kind of
interesting to me i remember
you guys remember when you were younger
there was that service called cha-cha
and you could like text them a question
and they would answer it
totally like i think there was a real
person on the on the other end who would
just google the question you had
because google wasn't on your phone at
the time yep that's exactly what it was
and that's kind of like what you're
doing and so my question is this
how do you scale that and you just think
of a ton of guards
and also what other services can i apply
this to
so that's exactly the way that we think
about it kind of inside of our four
virtual walls of the company um so so
number one
the the number one thing that we do to
scale is that if you think about the the
old business of security right like a
guy or a gal
sitting at a chair watching the entrance
to you know a corporate building
that is inherently not scalable right
you have no
levers because you have a physical chair
and
what's neat about deep sentinel and the
big kind of aha moment for me is that
there's all this internet stuff that can
sit between the cameras and the guards
and
when there's internet stuff that means
you can instrument it that means you can
you can
start measuring things and then like uh
what i did at amazon and my last couple
companies you once you have data you can
start optimizing it you can start
looking at what are the real problems
what are the things that aren't problems
how do i
how do i make the guards into super
guards right like
in fact at our office we have an iron
man at the entrance because that's
that's the way that we think about this
is that our technology turns these
you know regular awesome guards into
super guards that can instead of having
four guards protecting one property you
have one guard protecting 100 one guard
protecting 200 properties
because all of the the the ai
filters out events it also sends them
clips that it thinks are interesting
that they should look at like hey here's
a clip from 30 seconds ago
maybe these things are tied together and
so as you do more and more of that it's
not like we're getting rid of the people
but we're making each individual person
more powerful right and more engaged in
their work
um the last thing i'll toss out about
this too is that
one of the other things that a lot of
people don't know about guards is let's
take
let's take like the most badass special
forces guy in the world right like
i'm ripped i've been trained for for
years and i'm going to put you
on night watch so you get to stay up
between 10 a.m and 6 a.m
and you're in an area that's like this
dangerous
it doesn't matter how badass you are
right like the tendency to fall asleep
when there's nothing happening for eight
hours in a row
is incredibly high one of the other neat
things about what we do is because we
spread this across all of our customers
there's always something happening we
don't have
like a lull time where our guards are
just not doing anything
they're always engaged and so we're
we're able to keep them
awake engaged like you know stimulated
in a way that allows us to provide like
what you just said you show the the
symbol on your cameras and bam within 10
seconds
there's a guard responding you can do
that 24
7. okay and so
where are the other opportunities like
this what do you call this this
model i don't know what you call it
where you have like real real people
doing stuff
yeah so um the the kind of like way to
still be called a tech company is you
make the human the second part so you
call it human in the loop that it's a
technology loop
and there just happens to be a human for
a tiny piece of the work
uh versus a traditional services
business where the human's doing
everything
and so human in the loop it's being
applied right now already in some other
industries like cyber security uses it
so
if they detect like what looks like an
intrusion or
like in the case of ricotta where they
don't detect it until after it's done
and the hackers release it
uh you know that you know that was a
that was a jab at them
but like you know the idea being that
the computers can detect things that are
kind of anomalous but the human really
applies
his or her intelligence to figure out
the last little bit so it's also being
applied like in
in medical telehealth right so you have
these experts
and you use technology around them to
make sure that
you take an expert who could only
generally be regional
historically but now a cancer expert
because of video conferencing and you
know
remote records and things like that can
actually have a lot more impact
for us what we think about are how do we
take this in a security context
because we want to stay in security and
how do we expand that to
a a virtual greeter at a multi-tenant
apartment building a skyrise in in new
york for example
how do we apply that to watching elderly
folks at home who may need
just a check-in every 15 minutes how do
we apply it to hotels
where you don't need to have a guard
there 24 7 but you need to check the
lobby every 15 minutes
and how do we do that at a cost that's
10 or 100 times less
than having a physical guard on location
that's interesting
how big is that how big is that market
of just checking in on
how many doormen are there in new york
you know you know it's it's a great
question actually one of the most
interesting things about this market is
uh
that it's it's pretty big right so the
alarm side's about 20 billion dollars
and then the guard side's like 20 to 30
billion dollars
but what what deep sentinel hits is like
this really kind of weird seem
where there hasn't been a solution at
all ever
and that price point's between about 100
bucks a month
and 10 000 a month there is nothing and
there's nothing there
not because there's no demand it's
supply side constraint there's never
been anybody that's been able to create
a product
that has a price point in that price
band
and so what we're finding is that
there's just this huge
vein of untapped demand right like a
hotel
let's use that example for that my
friend happens to own a few hotels
and he was telling me it costs him 3 000
a month to have this guard who's kind of
schlocky to be completely honest
i don't know if that's an appropriate
term on your podcast but
i've never never heard that word am i
the only jewish person on here okay so i
i'd say
so uh uh i don't know another word for
it but but he's schlocky so he's
he's kind of sloppy he you know he's not
really going to scare anybody away
and he slept to use another speech he
slept up to the place that's right
that's right
so he uh he shows up three times a night
this is for three thousand dollars a
month
he shows up three times a night and just
walks around the parking lot for about
five minutes
he gets a total of 15 minutes of
security over the course of 10 hours
and it's 3 000 bucks whereas with us
we'd be able to provide that service for
for maybe a thousand dollars a month and
there'd be someone watching 24 7 in case
something happened
it's just it's so massive what the
disruption is when you create something
where there's literally just been kind
of a vacuous hole
and so you know that's kind of a way of
me avoiding the question answering the
question but like
it's it's tens of billions of dollars
that's just untapped there's buildings
that would love to have somebody
greeting them in new york that don't
have someone
because their cost would be 20 000 bucks
a month but if it costs
a thousand bucks a month bam they do it
in a heartbeat so
what does your security person do when
they see somebody that is a potential
intruder are they calling the cops are
they like yelling through the camera hey
buddy back away
you know i'm a tough guy inside you know
what are they doing to actually
eliminate the threat so so there's
there's a bunch of different things that
that we do and and you know you
mentioned
two things on on kind of the ends of the
spectrum right and it's a
it's kind of like an escalation spectrum
and so on one end right like
hey i see a kid right that's the really
most innocent thing
and the kids kind of like poking at the
door and so we have a juvenile protocol
each of these things are in their own
little protocol that we train the guards
on
and that's part of what the technology
does the technology helps them know
the the potentially relevant protocols
to engage here
and the uh and with the kids you'd say
hey hey kiddo i see you're there
do you belong here right and that's kind
of the softest just touch
right then there's an adult that may be
looking a little creepy and then we say
hello this is deep sentinel security can
i help you
and that way if it does happen to be a
friend or family we're not insulting
them right so sam's
best friend from college that we've
never seen before shows up
and he decides that the right thing to
do is go right up to the door and start
looking through the windows without
knocking
you know that's the greeting he's going
to get he's going to know somebody's
there
but he's he's not going to necessarily
feel insulted right off the bat
if if somebody shows up and they've got
a crowbar it's
sirens on hey stop what you're doing
and and the the we automatically
escalate so either that guard or another
guard
is contacting police all of that's
happening within about 10 seconds
and that's where the neat the other neat
thing starts is that
because we have somebody watching our
calls to police
are very different than what they get
from like if you have adt or like some
some i'll use the word again some other
schlocky kind of home security system
adt calls and they say hi uh this is
this is becky from adt
uh i have a motion alarm in the living
room and the police say well
is it the homeowner is it a cat is it
the wind is it the dog and she says
no no this is becky from adt i have no
idea i'm just calling you because i
thought i'd waste your time
hangs up when we call i say hey i've got
a white male six foot three
he's got a crowbar and i have and he's
trying to break into this building
here's the address
i've just given them a description of
the suspect a description of the crime
and the existence of weapons every
single police department in the nation
that's what their dispatch is designed
to do and they
just described this at his own house
practicing crowbar combat i know right
and that's why two way out but that's a
that's a great joke but like that's why
two-way audio is really important
because by the way homeowners do do
crazy stuff
and so sometimes i have like a
sledgehammer that i use to like exercise
you've just described
me working out well and we'll say hey
like are you there and you say no no
it's me sam here's my special code word
and then we don't call the police so
when we call police it's a hundred
percent verified
our calls are 100 verified and most
people don't know this
when alarm companies call the police and
ask for dispatch it's 99
false alarms in fact freakonomics wrote
a little piece about this
and they're just like it's it's
horrendous it's a waste of police time
right and so most police jurisdictions
have actually passed laws where they
don't have to respond at all to alarm
calls
yeah that's what i was gonna say in san
francisco i feel like i can call the
police and say hey this guy's got a gun
to my head
and they'd be like well you know let's
see if you could if you can resolve that
with your hoa before we uh send somebody
out there right then you can get his
name and call us on monday
that'd be great right and so how many
crimes have you guys stopped
we stop about 15 to 20 crimes a day
i mean and that's crimes means like
stealing packages it means everything
right drum beats right like it's just
it's stealing packages it's attempted
break-ins it's assault
why don't you have a a tick-tock channel
that publishes
every crime that stopped just the
footage of the crime we do it
it's the stopped video channel yeah send
everyone to it
okay i gotta get what is it called it's
stopped it's on youtube we're just
starting tick tock we just found tick
tock right like
i'm old sorry so like i didn't i didn't
really get tick-tock my kids were on it
and they were like
look at me dance and we did like the
dances but i didn't really think about
it as like hey let's post these things
on there
uh people are loving it on tick tock so
because
on youtube what is it it's stopped what
it's the uh
it's the stopped deep sentinel stopped
video series
and every single week we produce the the
best 5 10 15 20.
oh it's amazing these have thousands of
views great good for you
some of them have close to a million i
think yeah we have a couple that have a
million
uh and it's it's cool like it's what's
neat about it is it kind of taps into
um you know if you've ever been the
victim of one of these crimes like you
you want nothing more than to get back
whether you're getting back at that
individual person or just like
getting back at the world because it
makes you feel powerless
and one of the neatest things that you
know we actually don't really publicize
that we do
as a company um is we we actually reach
out to people that have been the victims
of
of like really heinous crimes and
uh you know a lot of times i i reach out
personally and say like hey
i i i'm not asking you to promote us i'm
not asking you to do anything
i just want you to know that we've
created a product that actually can make
you feel safe in your own skin safe in
your own home again
and i'd love to just give it to you for
the next six months
and uh and it's the neatest thing like i
actually
this morning i happened to drive by
there was a there was a home invasion in
my hometown
um last year and i gave the system to
these people that live in pleasanton and
uh and i happened to be by their house
this morning so i stopped in this
morning and the husband answered the
door
and you know he's like he's a like a big
tough dude
right and he he's not the type person
that you would expect to say like i'm
really scared in my home
but we all have like our our kids or our
family or the moments where we're not
home or or like we're asleep
and it was really neat to hear him just
you know i
say like this is this has really changed
the way that
we live and and after something that
horrible
you know it's it's really life-changing
so we only have a few minutes left in
this segment but what i want to ask you
is
where's the opportunities based on what
you've discovered because i think
like i've actually read i like reading
about um companies that got big
20 30 40 years ago and there's a lot
like
the beginning of adp or adp what's
what's the security
um and a bunch of other like interesting
security basically the same company but
yeah yeah go ahead
uh a bunch of companies that are just
like like um
the guy who started um you know
wonderful brands
like he got a lot of his wealth i
believe from a security guard company
like security guard companies are just
kind of interesting to me for some
reason it's kind of weird
um in this space with this like
human in the loop service in the
security space
where's interesting opportunities that i
wouldn't know about because i'm not
involved um one of one of the ones that
we see a lot of
uh is construction recently um
and uh the
what's what's interesting about
construction yards is you have these
massive amounts of assets
with no security like literally no walls
most of the time
right like sometimes you have chain link
fences and and that's gonna generally in
security like speaking outside of like
deep sentinel in terms of human in the
loop
one of the other interesting things that
that we're seeing is like
just the movement of stuff seems pretty
unsolved right like
there are still companies that make a
hundred million dollars a year
and they have a line of business called
cash like
in the age of venmo and in the age of
paypal and in the age of apple money and
facebook money and
and every type of virtual currency in
the world there's still people getting
paid money to like put their lives in
danger
to go move pieces of paper around i mean
it seems like
so absurd i'm reading uh hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy right now in the
first
chapter it says like humans are
generally miserable because they spend
all their time
moving green paper around and green
paper doesn't make them happy
and and it made me think of like the
this this business that like
oh my god every every year people are
like scared and die
because they have to move the paper
around how dumb is that right like there
has to be something for
i mean just i don't know vapor take a
picture of it and vaporize it and then
digitize it i don't know
but that one seems like there's there's
just a a asinine amount of risk and
opportunity
there so construction is there one more
um
what's another i mean like most of them
are pretty obvious right like car
lots oh my god actually car lots are
interesting too because one of the
things that
that people don't realize is that
everyone thinks like oh my god car lots
everyone's going to come and steal a car
but that's kind of a big crime
actually the number one thing that we
see is people going and breaking into
cars at car lots
because uh there's just lots of um
catalytic converters
there's lots of stereos and there's lots
of leather and so
you know every once in a while there's
somebody like stealing cars off the
cartridge but what we see a lot of is
just
these people going and grabbing the
doors actually wait i'll go with one
more meth
so meth uh meth is a
a horrible thing right um but what meth
has led to
is like this really weird pattern of
mail theft
and i call it agricultural mail theft
and so one of the things that you'll see
this a little bit on extra like hey i
saw this guy
like going and checking my door handles
or checking my mailbox and then it goes
on next door and everyone in the
neighborhood for like 15 miles says
oh i saw that same gal or guy too
and meth has created this entire
lifestyle where these people
actually go and farm neighborhoods and
they'll go in a
cyclical schedule go from this
neighborhood tonight to this
neighborhood next week in this
neighborhood
and they literally check every single
door every single mailbox
as again kind of tending it like they
would be tending their plants in
agriculture and uh and it's just really
it's a weird what are they stealing is
they're just stealing mail or they're
still
stealing something violated um they're
stealing wallets and and mail that's
typically checked they're actually
pretty careful and when i say
agriculture like they're actually
careful so
so when they put your mail back it's
very infrequent you see them just
throwing it on the ground
because that's that that like ruins
their
their agricultural area so it's actually
really interesting when you see the
video
they're like they open your door and
then they're very careful when they put
your mail back because the last thing
they want is for somebody to find out
and frequently again if you look at next
door what you'll find and this is why
deep sentinel
is needed everywhere is they'll go be
like oh my god i went back for the last
three months
and this guy's been coming every four
days and i only happen to notice this
one time because he took something too
valuable to me
and and it's just this really consistent
theme across america
that your doors are getting checked your
mailbox is getting checked
way more than you're aware of
i've caught a bunch of people my
camera's being being weird i get an
email where it says a guard intervened
i've caught a few people uh i hate it
yeah it's almost made me freak out more
now that i know
well i mean i i it the the the good news
is that you know you do have a layer of
protection the bad news is you now know
like for real like if
if you had a ring you're getting 100
alerts a day and so you just didn't know
because
who's going to comb through all 100 of
those alerts every single day just not
it's not worth it well i appreciate you
uh coming on this is super interesting
i've been a fan of your product
so it's nice to talk to the creator of
it uh one of the creators of it
um this is pretty badass um well thank
you guys yeah
i mean as you can tell like i'm super
proud of it i'm happy to talk about it
any day if you put me on for five hours
i'd keep going right like
i love it it's it's the neatest company
i've ever had a chance to touch
and i'm i'm so proud to be able to touch
people
did you help build ring or did you work
at amazon i worked at amazon
yeah so i was there way before ring
times how long what did you start there
uh 2002. holy moly i bet we should have
you on another time just ask stories
about that too
i i have lots of stories there's lots of
people that have great stories about
amazon amazon is such a neat company to
have watched go from
you know when i joined every single uh
every single quarter the wall street
journal would run a story
when does amazon shut down because it
just isn't sustainable
what uh number employee were you oh gosh
uh
you guys were in the thousands at that
point probably like three thousand
something like that probably you uh
haven't sold too many shares
all of them oh my god
but good good wait good news though i
sold them in order to start redfin
so and i held on to some redfin stock so
i did not know that dude you've been
doing it wait redfin the real estate
thing
redfin the real estate thing i didn't
know you started that so you've done all
types of man
i tried to yeah it's been it's been
really neat i've had i've been i've had
a very blessed career
um but again like what's neat about this
one is you know redfin's really really
cool
we invented interactive mapping but this
business
the number of times i get an email every
single week that says you changed my
life
that's tech companies get criticized for
like oh you're just building toys and
frivolous stuff you're like
it's like you're literally saving lives
uh so you get to do both you got to do
fun
you know tech with with all kinds of
crazy involved and
at the same time you're saving lives so
i like that i'm jealous of my friend
james
who invested in you guys early on i
remember seeing him post about it on
facebook and i was like this is a pretty
good idea
and what i didn't put i didn't think
about at the time because i was like how
are they going to scale this up i
thought
oh they're going to do labor arbitrage
they're going to get people the
philippines to watch your stuff
and uh you know it'll just be a lower
hourly rate you know and the price point
will be you know sort of high
unachievable for most but what you're
saying is smart which is
one guard is going to have 100 houses
under monitor most of them
most of the time nothing is happening so
you don't need eyeballs on the screen
and the ai is going to basically say
something's going on on house
42 42 pops up human eyes decide is this
good or bad
next swipe to the next and so it's
really it's actually more than human in
the loop
it's in my opinion like these should be
called something else this should be
called likes
you know super services or something
like that because it's taking a
example and it's scaling it like a
superhero where it's like oh
what if that security guard could not
just watch one house but actually could
watch 100 houses now you have a super
service
that can scale in the way that services
typically can't and so i think that's
even more i know for pitch decks you use
hooping a loop and
i've seen that a bunch but i i think
super services
i freaking love that dude i'm gonna
steal that from you if that's okay
yeah that's great uh i think this is
awesome and now
now i'm kicking myself because i'm like
oh that this actually if i'd asked
one question
earlier this would have made sense to me
and now it does so thanks for coming on
and
and uh explaining it to us hey thank you
and and if you're still interested we're
raising another round this year so hey
uh you know let me know see the only
problem is i'm a cheap indian dude who's
like oh the price back then
the price then would have been i don't
know what you could raise your first
round at maybe 10 million or something
like that 20 million i have no idea what
it was but
uh now i bet like have you you've raised
an a right uh we're in the process of
raising the a right now so
okay actually i'm going to email you i'm
going to invest in this company anyways
you got to send it to me too look you
guys are i'm not taking your spot
we can both get in baby can we i mean
you've raised 24 million dollars
um right or 23. we've raised we've
raised a bit we have a we have a really
unique investment vehicle that's open
right now so
you know if you're serious uh there
there is an opportunity
because you know adt and these guys what
are the other security
companies the big ones i've looked into
this before but they're all
multi-billion dollar
sort of sleeping giant incumbent types
that
for them to do something like this they
either have to buy you or they have to
like
change their dna inside their bodies
which is not going to happen so
has a 6 billion market cap
and wait i'm so confused adt has 5
billion in revenue
and a 6 billion market cap is that right
if you look at their enterprise value
that's the secret
they have a 6 billion dollar market cap
because they have 10 billion dollars in
debt so they actually have an enterprise
value of 15 billion dollars
16 billion okay so there's some by the
way
and the other way we could do this is if
you happen to have 10 billion dollars i
could borrow
i could do that too yeah
this podcast doesn't pay that well
[Laughter]
yeah we uh we missed that one
but uh dude send me the information i'm
definitely interested if you wanted to
talk about it or you're willing to have
either of us
that sounds awesome happy to do it it's
funny how such a small thing makes
difference i saw the video sam posted
and the operator the security guard who
spoke back was like clearly not like you
know
my relative in india and i was like oh
wait this is actually going to
feel totally different to have a human
who's got your back
who feels like a trusted american voice
there with you
right there with you and then like right
right now in my neighborhood our front
gate we have like a door guy just
sitting there all day couldn't stop
anybody if we wanted to
um but you know just sort of useless uh
you know
there's all these little points of
failure whether it's mail
it's the doorman it's your personal
house it's my for example for e-commerce
or warehouse
yeah they spend a lot of money you know
just guarding because they have millions
of dollars of goods in their warehouse
and um and it's just so inefficient so
capital inefficient the way they try to
uh secure
you know have security for those things
nowadays because you have alarms
which are just going to be like kind of
just a sound you know you're playing an
mp3 to protect you
or or you have a human you've got you
know a club
spotify now by the way mp3s are the old
ones that's right
for you we're going to stream we're
going to stream the security to you or
you have a guard who's 99.9 percent of
the time gonna do nothing
and um and so it just doesn't make sense
right like so
finally you know a solution that makes
more sense and no i'm not paid to say
this it just makes sense to me
well i i if i can i'll tell you one more
story one of the things that got me
off my butt to do this was uh there was
a story
of this elephant that escaped a zoo
and the video was uh the elephant
not not a small animal right like an
elephant
right and the elephant did not escape
the zoo by going around the guard the
guard was
sitting at the at the gate and and like
you know the chairs tilted back the way
that you expect the chair to be told
guard is totally asleep and a freaking
elephant
walks right by him and leaves the zoo
and you're just like
there has to be something better than
this this is ridiculous
has there ever been a conversation like
in san francisco there's all these car
break-ins like
can a city adopt this do you ever do you
think a city realistically is going to
ever adopt this where
you know the cameras are on the street
post or you know on the lights and
basically
you can guard the whole street of cars
that way or no you know we've we've
talked to a couple
of cities about it the thing that i
don't like is i don't like the idea of
big brother
being part of the government like one of
the things i really like from kind of an
ethical
visit i'm a pretty principled guy i like
to think um
is that by making this surveillance
private and focused on private property
and protecting that property
in service to that individual you don't
have that like panopticon
risk of turning into you know the evil
eye and and uh you know we never
question who our customer our customer
is the person that that pays us and owns
this property and that's a
it's a tried and true like deep
principle of
you know american liberty that's fair
enough i like that yeah the person who
buys it is the one who's opting in to
their own
protection basically yeah yeah that's
right my um
someone just rang my doorbell and i know
that because my
i just got a notification on my phone
that deep senator is talking to him
this is where you're gonna people are
going to be like
you didn't know they rang your doorbell
because they rang your doorbell like
[Music]
i can't i can't hear it but i know that
uh i
could i can see on my phone i just got
the notification i love it
it it makes me feel so much safer for my
i've got two little girls
and i absolutely love it
it's great i'm digging this i'm i mean i
can see my wife in our courtyard this is
awesome i'm a fan
well thank you guys i love i love
getting the opportunity to be here thank
you so much for bringing me on and uh
you know and and for being a good
customer thank you hold on
good talking man
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like my days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
[Music]
uh